[Music]
gas barbecues were invented in the 1960s
by an arkansas
gas company they redesigned a charcoal
grill to run on bottled propane
people were drawn to the instant flame
and the gas barbecue
became a hot commodity
gas barbecues run from basic to
extremely high end
there's no fussing with charcoal
briquettes you just press the starter
button
and adjust the flame to the desired
intensity
then close the lid and you're cooking
with gas
[Music]
making a gas bbq begins with a laser
it cuts holes for screws knobs and
piping
into a sheet of high gauge steel it will
take approximately 50 steel sheets to
make the entire gas bbq
this sheet will be used for the grille's
front hood
computerized tools punch out various
holes in the next steel sheet
it will be used to make the barbecue's
cart
[Music]
the holes are strategically placed for
vents and other features
[Music]
once holes are punched the team
transfers the sheet to a press brake
they place it between the jaws
repeatedly to make numerous bends
[Music]
the first set of bends create a ledge
for the grille to sit on
[Music]
other bends transform the flat sheet
into a three wall box
that will serve as the back and sides of
the barbecue's cart
the next employee places a sheet within
the walls of the box
this will serve as the base of the
barbecue's cart
he clamps cross braces to the cart and
welds the parts together
[Music]
the barbecue card has taken shape
they return to the front hood piece it's
been rounded since we last saw it
a worker assembles two steel side panels
to the hood
the side panels are made of thicker
steel than the rest of the barbecue
because they will need to support hinges
and springs
[Music]
an employee presses a belt sander
against the welded seams to clean them
up
then he sands the entire surface of the
hood so that the seams disappear
[Applause]
[Music]
he inserts the temperature gauge and
secures it to the hood
from the inside down the line
another team member joins the rear part
of the hood with a barbecue's firebox
he installs the gas manifold system
complete with valves that control the
burners
he hooks up the gas line that will fuel
the barbecue's rotisserie
he covers the manifold with the plate
that has holes for the valves
he places infrared ceramic burners
inside the firebox
he connects the igniter system for
lighting the gas bbq
[Music]
and fastens all the cables together
[Music]
now he fires up the barbecue and
inspects it for leaks or any other
operational problems
[Music]
once the barbecue passes inspection the
employee
mounts a glossy steel panel to the front
he attaches a knob to the end of the
igniter
[Music]
he installs stainless steel grates above
the burners
[Music]
he hinges the front hood to the back one
[Music]
once the hinges have been secured he
lowers the lid to confirm that it closes
tightly over the firebox
[Music]
the team transfers the barbecue to the
cart
the cart has been equipped with doors
and drawers
[Music]
after they weld the firebox to the cart
this gas bbq is on its way to a patio
near you
15 hours in the making it will provide
years of grilling pleasure
no need to slave over a hot stove in the
kitchen just turn on the grill
and enjoy the great outdoors
you